[Music]
so
welcome how can i help you
[ __ ]
hey traveler i've been looking for you
everywhere how's that wind glider i gave
you last time
it seems but then again you don't have a
gliding license
do you
a gliding light isn't it obvious
you gotta oh but yeah
you've been gliding all over the place
so you can look no way the night you
need to pass an exam
and oh today i'm here as an example i
gave you your wing glider so this is my
responsibility an exam
what a pain in the butt i'm sure you'll
glide through it i mean
the whole city saw how well you flew the
day that but we do need to respect the
rules and
here take this gliding manual no need to
memorize it for example
only one person per wing glider no
carrying anything over the set weight
limit
anyway be sure to read it okay i had to
read a low
wow that's upgrade come find me when
ah the knights of evonius
when the first wisp of wind brushed
across the land
birds that yearned for the sky had wings
but no way to fly
[Music]
they asked the animal god how can we
reach the heavens
to which the animal god replied
you have yet to find that which is most
important
as the god spoke the wind thrust the
seeds of a dandelion
high into the sky the birds thrust out
their wings
but the breeze was all too mild
leaving them to stumble across the earth
so they went to the gorge where the wind
showed off its wild and
incomparable strength they threw
themselves off the cliff
and slap their wings amongst the howling
winds
until they were able to fly freely in
the sky
to the animal god they went to gleefully
say
we understand now all we needed was a
stronger wind to fly
in reply the animal god said what you
lacked was not wind
but courage it is courage that has
allowed you to become
the first flying birds of this world
hmm that's a cool story but is the
night's gliding manual really written
in that style huh